la question qui se pose à moi il ya vaut
sûrement si vous êtes étudiant
ou déjà jeunes cadres dirigeants les
questions fondamentales que nous devons
nous poser ne sont pas seulement quoi
faire mais surtout quel sens donner à ce
que nous faisons j'ai 26 ans et je suis
un jeune héritier ayant repris depuis
six ans le groupe fondé par mon père à
madagascar
évidemment la première question que je
me suis posée sait quels sont mes
options forcément la première option a
été de me dire ne rien faire j'y
réfléchis trois secondes
cette option était tentante mais plus
sérieusement est elle possible
bien sûr que non au delà d'avoir aussi
hérité d'un sens aigu de l'ambition des
volontés de réussite économique et une
insatiable envie de découvrir et
d'innover
j'ai aussi hérité du sens des
responsabilités
cet héritage agrobusiness c'est aussi la
responsabilité d'assurer le
développement des familles qui
travaillent au sein du groupe familles
et leurs enfants qui dans une région
fortement touchée par les risques
climatiques
donc le très peu d'alternatives de
subsistance autres que celles offertes
par les activités de mon groupe
alors la vraie question pour moi plutôt
été comment faire quand aujourd'hui les
modèles d'affaires semble montrer leurs
limites pour ne pas dire leur
incohérence
et comment faire quand les urgences du
développement induit aussi urgence
environnementale et sociale
notre système de vie est tout sauf
pérenne nous avons des millions de
références ou des explications
scientifiques qui sont à notre
disposition et nous pourrons ici on
avoir pour des heures à vous expliquer
ce que vous savez déjà
j'ai juste choisi ici
ah les ressources prenez le temps avec
moi d'apprécier apprécié façon de parler
cela signifie qu'à l'échelle de la
planète
nous avons pêché plus de poisson a battu
plus d'arbres et cultiver plus de terre
que ce que la nature nous a offert au
courant d'une année quant à nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre elles
ont été plus importantes que ce que nos
forêts et nos océans peuvent absorber ce
que je pense en fait c'est que nous
consommons mal mais surtout nous
produisons de la mauvaise façon
nous avons réfléchi le travers nous
devant et je me sens le devoir d'innover
au delà de maintenir les réussites
économiques dont j'ai la charge
je dois aussi construire de nouveaux
modèles pérenne cohérent il nous faut
élaborer des nouveaux modèles d'affaires
mais comment faire et surtout est-ce
possible
comment faire donc prenons un exemple
concret dans notre groupe nous avons des
fermes de cafés situés dans des zones de
déforestation massive et mais père
aimait mes terres productives emploie
200 personnes à madagascar et j'ai deux
objectifs
je veux générer une valeur ajoutée qui
leur permettent de sortir de leur
pauvreté
je veux en même temps promouvoir la
biodiversité
mais comment faire d'autant plus que la
première remarque est la suivante
biodiversité malgache
on connaît mais le cafi malgache at il
un avenir
face aux géants du brésil et du vietnam
eh bien le café malgache est cultivé au
coeur de nos forêts au milieu des
baobabs et des lémuriens
nous avons des espèces de café à très
faible taux de caféine avec des fèves
très grosses comme des cerises ou très
petites comme les lentilles alors vous
dites sûrement mais c'est invendable non
commercialisable dans un monde
standardisé aujourd'hui
eh bien c'est ce que je pense et dont
l'univers du café tout est normé et
c'est là dessus que j'ai commencé à
analyser les dogmes établis et j'ai
commencé à innover et c'est l'histoire
de saint-exupéry qui m'a inspiré en 1927
saint-exupéry vie au sud du maroc entre
deux déserts l'atlantique et le sahara
un jour il pose son avion breguet dont
les dunes il trouve alors cette pierre
très lourde ce sont des métiers aux
rites son imagination le fait qu'un tour
le petit prince né en une dizaine de
minutes au milieu des deux déserts si
aujourd'hui un des livres les plus lus
au monde
mais pourquoi je vous raconte cette
histoire est bien le petit prince nous
invite à penser d impossible le petit
prince nous invite à réfléchir à de
nouveaux modèles reste un peu avec moi
et le petit prince au maroc au maroc
aujourd'hui nous cultivons des algues
marines qui capture les micro plastiques
ensuite les algues sont utilisées pour
produire du biogaz et de l'engrais ce
qui permettra à terme de réduire
l'exploitation des mines de phosphate
je trouve cette inspirant cet
enchaînement à c'est inspirant mais vous
demandez quel rapport avec le café et
bien avant de répondre j'ai une question
pour vous qui s'ils consomment du café
lever la main éloquent mais pas
surprenant le café la deuxième boisson
la plus consommée au monde après l'eau
et avant l'alcool mais au risque de vous
surprendre
quand vous prenez une tasse de café vous
ne consommer que 0,2 pour cent de la
biomasse comme et cultivateurs récolte
vous m'avez suivi n'est ce pas enfin
j'espère 99 % de déchets il ya un trésor
exploiter et de la cohérence à retrouver
la nature nous met à notre disposition
99 % de matière là sous nos yeux
il nous en faisons quoi et bien
aujourd'hui personne ne paie ni ne
mangent le marc de café ni la pulpe mais
la pulpe est une source importante
d'antioxydants alors écoutez bien la
recette si je mélange la pulpe sécher le
café avec des graines de café torréfié
et que je rajoute du beurre de cacao est
un peu de sucre végétales j'ai un kart
est solide
vous me dites sûrement mais berti
personnes ne mangent du café solide
normal
pas vous vous ne saviez pas mais dites
moi vos enfants qui passent trois heures
par jour sur leur smartphone
qu'est ce qu'il faisait il ya dix ans ou
prenons un exemple plus proche de nos
propos vous connaissez les boissons
énergisantes saturé de caféine et bien
elles n'existaient pas il ya moins de
dix ans et elle représente aujourd'hui
un marché de plusieurs millions de
dollars
écoutez bien le calcul si je vends mon
café solide au même prix que red bull
monster et les autres notre chaîne de
valeur dégage plus de 100000 euros la
tonne de café un tour de force créatif
quand aujourd'hui la tonne de café est
100 fois moins élevé eh bien les
rendements naturel de café sont entre
800 kilos et une tonne 5 à l'hectare
nous avons à madagascar des espèces de
café qui pousse dans la forêt
cela veut dire qu'il faut tout d'abord
une forêt de grands arbres pour qu en
dessous puisse pousser les plantations
et avec mon café solide qui génère
cent mille euros la tonne le café j'ai
assez pour un acheté des terrains dénudé
et replanter de la forêt de étendre les
plantations de café en dessous 3 mieux
rémunérer les cultivateurs 4 dégager de
la valeur pour l'entreprise et cinq
maintenir ma dynamique protectrice de
l'environnement
mes plantations sont bio touton
biodiversité et je n'ai nul besoin
d'engrais bio chimie ni des ogm
vous posez sûrement la question mais ce
modèle existe déjà et bien sûr je résume
donc économiquement rentable
régénération de la nature et de la
biodiversité mieux pour le consommateur
donc vous enrichissant pour le
cultivateur et digne pour le producteur
alors vous allez rapidement apprécier
les effets de notre petit cadeau nous
avons une entité partenaires qui assure
la commercialisation de notre café
solide et les pays scandinaves sont les
premiers consommateurs et nous
développerons les marchés les uns après
les autres et je suis entrepreneur
aujourd'hui comme le désire tout
entrepreneur de la nouvelle génération
je suis fidèle à mes convictions
d'apprendre d'innover et de passer de la
réflexion à l'action n'est certe cela
prend du temps
bien sûr j'ai besoin de concrétiser ce
que je m'imagine et ce n'est que le
début mais agir en respectant ce qui est
important pour tous méritent engagement
conviction et enthousiasme sans renier
notre volonté économique d'entrepreneurs
nous avons besoin de rejoindre et
agrandir les cercles d'entrepreneurs
engagés à développer de nouveaux modèles
cohérent sur le plan économique
environnemental et social
pour conclure réfléchissez
au sens de vos actions innover et
devenez ambassadeur de la biodiversité
malgache de mon programme de
régénération de forêt déguster mon café
bonne dégustation
[Applaudissements]